Hello and welcome to 3ABN Today Bible
Q&A. I'm so happy that you can join us.
My name is Ian Vandervok. I'm going to
be your host for today's program. And
this is as always and I pro you probably
heard me say this before. This is one of
my favorite programs because we get to
answer your Bible questions. So, keep
sending them in because we love to study
God's word. We love to talk about God's
word and especially with you get to
answer your questions. So, keep sending
them in. And uh the way that you do
that, I'm going to give you a couple
ways that you could send in your
questions. So the first that you can do
is you can text them in. You can text
them to 618-2283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
You can also email your questions to us
at bibleqa3abn.tv.
For those of you who are listening on
radio, I'll say it again. It is
bibleqa3abn.tv.
And lastly, if you're on social media,
you could just send us a direct message
to uh 3BN_official
on Instagram. So, those all the ways
that you could send in your questions.
We love to receive them. Please don't
stop. We love to answer your questions
and it's just such a blessing to have
you here and to join us in this ministry
together. And also, I just want to say a
special thank you for your prayers and
your financial support of this ministry
because it's what allows us to do what
we do and to continue to spread this
gospel throughout the whole world and
have an opportunity to reach lives
because we know that people, you know,
they're asking some serious questions.
It's not just biblical topics, but it's
also practical Christianity that people
want to know how to live their life, you
know, in a biblical way. Yeah. So,
please keep sending in your questions,
keep supporting this ministry through
your prayers and financial support. and
we thank you very much for that.
>> Amen.
>> Now, I want to introduce to you the ones
that are on our uh table here today who
are going to be answering your
questions. And I'm going to just start
right across the way here and begin with
Pastor James Rafferty. Thank you for
joining us.
>> Good to be here, Ian. As always, look
forward to the questions and the
answers. It's great to study the word of
God.
>> Amen. Amen. Now, this is also special
for me because we have a newcomer here.
>> Amen. to uh 3BN Bible Q&A, but she's not
new to 3BN, but she is new to this
program, and I am excited to introduce
you to Fotini Martinez. It is a blessing
to have you here today.
>> Praise the Lord. Thank you for having
me. I work in accounting here at 3ABN,
so I'm not typically on the set, but if
you've called in and had a question
about a receipt or donation, you've
likely spoken with me,
>> and I'm excited to be here now and share
what I've been able to study through the
questions that were sent in.
>> Amen. Amen. And it's a pleasure to have
you here. And last but not least, we
have our brother here, Pastor Ryan
Johnson. So glad you could be here
today.
>> It's wonderful to be here, brother. And
I think you said it. It's important that
as we have our questions that we talk
together, study the word together. The
Lord bless us when we study together.
And I also love the full circle. Many of
you have met Sister Fotini. And now you
meet her again in this aspect of sharing
the gospel. So God is good, isn't he?
>> Amen. Amen. And you know, one of the
things that I love about this program,
cuz sometimes when I'm on the other side
answering the questions, Yeah.
>> is, you know, sometimes we'll get
questions from you that I'll personally
select because I have no idea how to
answer them. And it actually forces me
to go into God's word and to study for
myself and give you that answer as well.
So, it challenges us as well. So, thank
you for that.
>> But, uh, before we begin and open up
God's word and discuss what he has for
us to learn today, let's go to the Lord
in prayer.
>> Amen. Our loving heavenly father, Lord,
we just thank you for this day. We thank
you for this opportunity that we have to
learn, to grow, and to study your word
and to share uh with those who are
watching right now what you have shared
with us. And Father, we just ask for
your Holy Spirit to be present that you
would work through our hearts and our
minds and that you would just help us to
receive whatever message it is that you
would have us for today and be with each
person that is presenting here today.
Lord, I pray that you would fill them
with the words that you would have them
to speak and maybe even things you
haven't even told them yet and you would
just speak through them. Lord, we love
you. We thank you and we praise you and
we ask this in the precious and holy
name of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> All right, Pastor James, I'm going to
come to you first and this is a text
that was sent in by Anthony from Ohio
and the question is, can you explain
Revelation 4:es 6-8? Also, who are the
seven spirits of God in Revelation 4:5?
>> Great question. Thank you, Anthony from
Ohio. We could also include with
Revelation 4 6-8, uh, Ezekiel chapters 1
and 10 and Isaiah 6:es 1-3.
All of these scripture references have
similar descriptions. They are
describing the four beasts or the four
living creatures. And these creatures
represent heavenly angels. Now the
reason why the living creatures have
different faces is because those
different faces are symbolic
representations of how angels minister
in God's service.
>> So the four angels faces represent the
ministry of the angels. For example,
they have a face like a man. Well,
angels often come to this earth in the
guise of men. And we can read that in
Hebrews chapter 13 and verse two. They
also have the face of a lion. And that
represents their power and authority.
They have the power and authority of
heaven because we're told that Jesus
Christ is a lion of the tribe of Judah.
So they come in the authority of Jesus
Christ. Revelation 5:5. They also have
the face of an ox or a calf and that
represents their sacrifice and service
for God and for humanity. According to
Hebrews 1:13-14, the ox or the calves
were part of the sacrificial service. So
this symbolizes the angel's willingness
to be ministering spirits and to
sacrifice their time and their efforts
to save us in God's service. And then
the eagle, the eagle is the fourth
beast's description, and this represents
their speed. In Daniel 9 and verse 21,
we're told that they fly as the speed of
uh light. So we're talking about very
fast movements with the angels. In
Ezekiel, it talks about them going
forth, back and forth like lightning.
Now the other symbolic factors in the
vision are the number four. Four
represents the four directions of the
earth, north, south, east, and west.
Meaning that the angels are everywhere
present. They are looking over, watching
over each one of us. In fact, each one
of us is given a guardian angel
according to Matthew chapter 18. And
then we see that the angels are full of
eyes. Now eyes are symbolic of the
allseeing reporting power that the
angels are given. They're recording and
seeing everything that's done on planet
earth according to Ezekiel 9:11 and
Genesis 18 and 19. And they report that
back to heaven. Uh they also say holy,
holy, holy. So they're praising and
worshiping the father, the son, and the
holy spirit according to Matthew 28:1
19. And then it talks about the seven
spirits. Now, that would be a reference
to the completeness of the Holy Spirit.
And this would be confirmed in Isaiah
11:1 and 2, where the Holy Spirit rested
upon Christ in a sevenfold power. That's
Isaiah 11:es 1 and two. We don't have
time to look at that verse, but you can
look that up and see the seven-fold
spirit of God resting upon Christ. I
hope that helps, Anthony, to answer your
question.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Thank you, Pastor James. Very
informational. And what a you know what
a good reminder that angels are present
everywhere
>> and there to lead us and guide us. So
amen.
>> Uh so Foutini we're going to come to you
next.
>> Your question uh comes is an email from
Kurasowl and the question is what is the
difference between transgression and
iniquity and how do these relate to the
ark of the covenant? Also what was the
purpose or symbolism of the mana and
Aaron's budding rod in the original ark
of the covenant?
>> Yes. So, that is a loaded question and
it involves a lot of biblical topics
with really deep meaning. So, I'm only
going to touch on a couple of these
items that directly respond to the
question. And if you have more questions
about what I'm talking about, send that
in. Send that in as a question.
>> Amen.
>> Let's start with Exodus 34:7. We'll find
those terms. And it reads, "Keeping
mercy for thousands, forgiving iniquity
and transgression and sin, by no means
clearing the guilty, visiting the
iniquity of the fathers upon the
children and the children's children to
the third and fourth generation." So
here we have them listed out so we know
that they're different things. And I
know you didn't ask about sin, but I'm
throwing that in there as a bonus
because it explains the other two. So
then what I do is I go to my Greek Bible
and I read that same verse in Greek. And
for the word iniquity we have anomia.
For the word transgression we have
swalmata. And for the word sin we have
amaria which literally translates to
lawlessness, wrongdoing and sin. And
this is where we see dimensionality in
those three. And let's look at a couple
of verses that explain that in the
Bible. In Ezekiel 28:15,
speaking of Lucifer, you were perfect in
your ways from the day you were created
till iniquity was found in you. So, this
is an inner state of being, a turmoil,
rebellion that's inside that also has
the ability to shape your actions and
your life. Let's look at 1 Chronicles
10:13. So, Saul died for his
transgression, which he committed
against the Lord. So, transgression is
an action. we have a followup from that
inner state of being. And then when we
consider sin, let's look at 1 John 3:4,
which reads, "Whosoever committh sin
transgresseth the law, also the law, for
sin is the transgression of the law." So
here we see the offense resulting from
taking action on the premise of
lawlessness. So that's the difference
between those three. Now, what does that
have to do with the ark of the covenant?
Well, again, there's a lot of history in
the in the tabernacle,
but we're just going to focus on the
mercy seat for this purpose, which is
the ark of the covenant or the ark of
the testimony.
Initially, there were only the two
tables of stone that um God wrote the
ten commandments on with his finger and
we read that in Exodus 31:8.
But above that we have the mercy seat
where God dwelt and where we were able
to or in the time come and receive mercy
for transgression. Concerning the ark of
the covenant we see two main
characteristic. We see God's law and
God's mercy for us. And in the physical
realm we see that through the person of
Jesus Christ. God showed his mercy and
demonstrated his mercy and love towards
us in in Jesus. and he had to come to
that sacrificial point in order to
uphold the law.
>> And we read that in Daniel 9:24
concerning the 70week prophecy, which
again, Pastor Rafferty wrote a book
about. You should look at it, read it,
and if you have questions about that,
send those in.
>> But it says specifically what Jesus will
do. He will finish transgression, which
is that step away from God. And he will
make reconciliation for iniquity,
bringing us closer to God. Now again,
initially in the in the ark of the
covenant were only the ten commandments,
but we also read that later on a pot of
mana was put in there and Aaron's
budding rod, which again have a lot of
history to it. And there's a whole
sermon in the mana. If you go back to
Exodus 16:4, you can read about that.
But essentially, the Bible tells us that
God explained to Moses to put that in
there as a reminder of how he provided
for the children in Israel. And
concerning Aaron's budding rod, that is
that's in numbers 16 and 17. That
evolves from Kora's rebellion and that's
how that all came to play. You'll have
to go back and study that. But it's also
expressed in the Bible that it is there
in order to remind us that what God has
appointed that will follow through. So
when we come to the ark of the covenant,
we receive God's law and his promises
and covering over us. We receive the
mana which is God's provision for us.
And we also receive Aaron's budding rod,
which is the assurance that what God
says he will do, he does.
>> Amen.
>> That's a loaded question.
>> Amen. And how you fit that in in such a
short time. That was an absolute
blessing. And uh I don't think you're
going to be a newcomer anymore to Bible
Q&A.
>> Did you hear that Greek pronunciation?
>> Crispy, wasn't it?
>> I know, right? And for those of you who
don't know, Fotini actually speaks and
reads Greek. So that is definitely a
help when studying God's word. So, amen.
Thank you for that, Foutini. What a
blessing.
>> Praise the Lord.
>> All right, Pastor Ryan, we're going to
come to you now.
>> All right, so your first question here
was sent to us uh by text and it says,
"Could you please explain to me why
Christians who are really living for the
Lord die under tragic circumstances?"
>> You know what that seems at the surface
a very simple question, but this is a
heavy question and and I feel you. In
fact, this is a question about the
character of God and how he is toward
us. More people have had their faith
shaken by this question than by
doctrinal things and everything. And I
got to tell you, the question being why?
I'm just a man and I don't know why, but
we have some scriptures we can look at.
The song says we'll understand it better
by and by. Here is a difficult biblical
reality. Jesus told his disciples that
they would be persecuted and they were.
So while we do die and suffer, we are
not alone. This is why John says in the
first chapter of re Revelation, he says,
"I am your brother and companion in
tribulation. You are suffering. I am
suffering. You are killed all the day
long. So am I." So since we've set that
up, before we go further, let's just get
hit with a promise. It says in
Revelation 21:4, "God shall wipe away
all tears from their eyes. There shall
be no more death, neither sorrow nor
crying, neither shall there be any more
pain. For the former things are passed
away, it will pass away. Don't let
anyone or anything take that hope. That
is how we make it through the valley.
Even as God walks with us through the
valley of the shadow of death." But
here's a way of posing that question.
question originally was why really why
does bad things happen to righteous
folk? Look at it this way. Why does the
sun shine on the wicked? Oh, that's
inverting it. Well, here's a text. It
says that ye may be the children of your
father which is in heaven. For he maketh
his son to rise on the evil and on the
good. So that puts to bed the question
of what kind of God we serve. He's a
good God. He is a God who loves us. His
goodness is extended to all. So what's
really going on with this whole dying
and everything? Jesus puts it this way.
He says in l in John 16:33, "These
things I have spoken unto you that in me
you might have peace. In the world you
shall have tribulation, but be of good
cheer. I've overcome the world." Oh, I'm
tempted to preach on the overcome the
world. But there was a definition in
there. In the world
you shall have tribulation. He's
actually giving the reason right there.
Look what it says in Romans 8:22. It
says, "For we know that the whole
creation groanth and travaleth in pain
together until now." We are living in a
sinful world. We are experiencing the
results of sin and all of us have
sinned. So all of us are contributors.
This is why. But praise the Lord, he
does not leave us in this condition. We
go back to the promise. It will pass
away. But even though we are currently
in the way of the shadow of death, we do
not walk alone. So be encouraged, my
friend.
>> Amen. Amen. I think you just took us to
church there for
>> I can't help it. I keep going to church.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you for that. All
right, Pastor James, your next question
was sent to us via text and they ask,
"Can you explain 1 Timothy 4:es 1-5 as
it relates to unclean foods?"
Yeah. So 1 Timothy 4 1-5 were verses
that I really wrestled with when I first
became a believer and a 7th day advenist
specifically uh because they seem to
indicate the opposite of what the church
was teaching as I was studying with the
church. It basically says that the
spirit that is the holy spirit speaks
expressly that in the latter times and
we would say in the last days so this is
a prophecy that some shall depart from
the faith giving heed to seducing
spirits and doctrines of devils speaking
lies in hypocrisy and having their
conscience seared with a hot iron
forbidding to marry and to commanding to
abstain from meats. The King James says
food brma in the other translations of
the Bible com commanding to abstain from
food which God has created to be
received with thanksgiving of them which
believe and know the truth. For every
creature of God is good and nothing to
be refused if it be received with
thanksgiving for it is sanctified by the
word of God and prayer. I've studied
these Bibles for over these verses for
over 40 years. In fact, these are
central to our school of disciplehip and
the how to study the Bible class that I
do there. We go over these verses point
by point. So in the next three minutes,
we'll try to do what we do in a class
time probably of two or three hours. So
the spirit is speaking, prophesying of
those who are going to leave the faith.
Faith comes by hearing and hearing by
the word of God. So they're leaving the
word of God. They're giving heed to
seducing spirits, doctrines of devils.
So they're they're giving heed to
teachings that not are not in harmony
with the word of God. There's hypocrisy
there. Their conscience, that is their
co-perception, their moral perception is
being seared. So they're not perceiving
with God the way they're supposed to, of
course, because they're leaving the the
Bible and they're forbidding to marry.
We could look at Revelation 19, the
marriage of the lamb. 2 Corinthians 11 2
and 3 talks about the marriage in a
spiritual sense. I believe that's what
this is talking about, that connection
with God. They've left the faith.
They've given to heed the seducing
spirit. So they're disconnecting from
the marriage of the lamb that we are
called to. And they're commanding to
abstain. That means to hold themselves
off from food. Roma which God has
created. Now that word created is a key
word, one of two very important words.
It means to form originally or to found.
It's going all the way back to the book
of Genesis. They're holding off or
commanding people to hold off from what
God's originally gave us to eat. And
according to Genesis 1:29, God's
original diet was a vegetarian diet. Uh
what Daniel talked about in chapter 1,
pulse, anything sown. So we've got
fruits, vegetables, legumes, uh nuts,
we've got uh breads, all of the the
foods that God originally set apart for
us to eat, all of that did not include
animals. And so this next verse becomes
a little bit critical here because it
says, "Which God has formed or founded
originally to be received with
thanksgiving of them which believe and
know the truth." Of course, the truth of
the Bible, what the Bible actually
taught about the original diet for every
creature. Now, a lot of people will say
right there, "Oh, that's talking about
animals. That's talking about every
creature. You know, we can eat
alligators. We can eat pigs. We can eat
snakes. We can eat cows. We can eat
whatever we want." No. The word creature
again goes back to the same word as
creature in the the previous verse here
that is uh or created in the previous
verse that is God's original formation
same Greek word at its foundation for
everything God originally formed for
food is good and nothing to be refused
if it be received with thanksgiving for
it that is God's original diet was set
apart sanctified by the word of God and
of course by prayer. We need to pray
over our food, even if we're eating a
healthy diet today, because we've got
all kinds of chemicals, all kinds of
modifications that are taking place
right now in our world. And so, we need
to go organic. We need to try to get
food that hasn't been sprayed with all
these different chemicals. And we need a
prayer of our food and ask God to bless
it. But we also want to be in harmony
with his original diet and not hold
ourselves off from that original diet
because we're living in a time and our
minds and our hearts need as much of
God's original food as possible to
function the way that God originally
created us to function.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pastor James. I
still remember when you first shared
those verses with me and broke them
down. It just blew my mind. So, thank
you. Uh thank you for sharing that and
thank you for asking that question.
Thank you so much. All right. So
Foutini, we're coming back to you.
>> Now this was a text that was sent in and
the question is, can you please explain
Jeremiah 1:5? Not all of us are born
already established, but yet we are born
equal. They say
>> explain.
>> Absolutely. So what I hear in this
question is a concern about purpose, a
question of what is my place in the
world, a question of why am I even here?
What is my calling? That's how I
understood and perceived that because we
need to understand that life is never an
accident. We're intentionally created by
God. Every one of us. And we're not born
and then God looks down on us and when
he's bored and he's like, "Oh, well,
there's so and so. They look like a
pretty good candidate to go and do
something kind. Maybe I should create a
plan for them." That's not how this
works. And the Bible is explicit on
that. But let's read Jeremiah 15 and
gain a better concept. Here it says,
"Before I," the Lord speaking, "formed
you," speaking to Jeremiah,
"in the womb, I knew you. Before you
were born, I sanctified you. I ordained
you a prophet to the nations." Now,
every time I hear I formed you, coming
from the mouth of God, I think of
Genesis, how he formed the man out of
the dust of the ground. And in the
Hebrew that the word formed is assa
which is quite artisal work like very
intimate uh carrying out of an idea and
creating that. So now let's also look at
Isaiah 49 verses 1 and 5. The wording is
a little bit different but it
complements Jeremiah 15.
Isaiah 49 chap uh verse one. Listen o
coastlands to me and take heed you
peoples from afar. The Lord has called
me from the womb, from the matrix of my
mother. He has made mention of my name.
Again, that intimate knowing of who you
are before you were born.
And here's the kicker in Isaiah 49:5.
And now the Lord says, who formed me
from the womb to be his servant. This is
where we have purpose coming in so that
Israel is gathered to him. For I shall
be glorious in the eyes of the Lord and
the God and God shall be my strength.
But especially in the case of Jeremiah,
knowing that purpose and hearing that
purpose isn't always comforting, which
is why he responds with, "Oh, but God,
you know, I can't speak. I'm a youth."
And then he receives that reassurance
from God in the face of blatant
objection. So what this means for you
and me is that we don't come into the
world seeking for a purpose. rather
because God has given us a purpose is
the reason for our life for the reason
why we're here. And more often than not,
we equate purpose with achievement or
with grandiose works. You know, not
everyone is an international evangelist.
Most Christians are not ordained
preachers. Well, then often times we
don't seem to see a purpose in what
we're doing as Christians. But our
purpose is remember to be servants of
God. That is why we were formed in the
womb as we read earlier.
And well at what about after that? After
we're purposely formed in the womb, you
know, God doesn't just speak his purpose
over us and then, you know, choose us
off into the world to be on our own.
Deuteronomy 3:18 provides a lot of
comfort. And the Lord, he is the one who
goes before you and he will be with you.
He will not leave you nor forsake you.
And so we are called to not fear nor be
dismayed. And so indeed you see here
that the one who created us has
established us before we were born with
the purpose of being servants to him.
And the only thing that God calls us to
do which we read in Micah 6:8 after he
has shown us what is good
>> to do justly, love mercy, and walk
humbly with our God.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you so much, Foutini.
We all have a purpose, a God-given
purpose. Amen. Amen.
>> Pastor Ryan.
>> Yes, sir. Our next question comes to you
and it's a text and the question is,
"Will those who eat clean meats be
lost?"
>> Well, that's kind of heavy, isn't it?
Will those who eat clean meats be lost?
If it's all right, let's invert that
one. Can those who eat clean meat be
saved?
>> Well, first of all, Pastor Rafferty has
broken this down and has talked about
the original plan. This is a question of
morality, and we're going to look at it
that way. We are in agreement here.
We're going to look at both sides of the
spectrum. So let's begin with a bibl
let's see if we can make a biblical
proof. Let's begin with the text right
from the Bible going to John 21 10 to12.
This is after the disciples who thought
they had lost Christ forever. They got
him back. And there is Jesus on the
shore and they're fishing. And Jesus
says unto them in verse 10, "Bring of
the fish which ye have now caught."
Verse 11, "Simon Peter went up and drew
the net to the land full of great
fishes." Verse 12, Jesus said unto them,
"Come and dine." What does dying mean?
That means eat. Come and eat. And none
of the disciples durst asked ask him,
"Who art thou?" Because they knew that
it was the Lord. I love that. We will
know him when we see him. But Jesus ate
fish both before and after his
resurrection. And it says in 2
Corinthians 5 21 that Christ knew no
sin. So therefore, eating clean meats
is not a sin and is not an issue of
salvation. We're going to look at this.
There is something in the Bible we'll
have a look at, but it is not for us to
earn our way into the kingdom. Well,
let's keep going. Maybe you're not
familiar with this idea of clean meats
and unclean meats, and you're watching
for the first time. If you go in your
word to Leviticus 11, the Lord gives
this outline of what is best for us. And
also seeing us do what the Lord said do
and being healthy and of clear and sound
mind. That sets us apart. That is a form
of sanctification. So if you read there
in Leviticus 11, you see that it says
don't eat pigs, don't eat birds of prey.
You can read that for yourself.
Shellfish and stuff. And this
distinction even existed before it was
outlined in Leviticus 11 and in some of
the other places because way back in
Genesis chapter 7 when the animals are
going into the ark, it says the clean
animals went into the ark by sevens and
the unclean animals by twos. Well, why
sevens? Well, because after the flood,
vegetation would be sparse and it would
have been presumptuous for them to just
sit there and not eat at all and starve.
And so the Lord allowed clean meats to
go onto the ark so that they could have
something to eat. All right. So, uh,
then what's up with the health message?
Something, and listen to me carefully,
can be allowed without being the
original design. Let me give some
examples. Matthew chapter 19 and verse
8, because of the hardness of your
hearts, divorce wasn't the original,
wasn't the original design. And then of
course Jesus also gives precepts and
rules on getting remarried right there.
Israel getting a king. That was not the
original design. And in 1st Samuel 8 5-7
God says they reject me but he allowed
it. Eating clean meats was not the
original design. There was no death in
Eden. Can you see no death in Eden? And
then there's Adam over there trying to
chop up some liver. No, no, no. That was
not the original design. And so then we
ask, what did God want for us? How can
we get back to what he wanted? And then
because of time, we won't read this. You
can go to Daniel chapter 1 and see this
beautiful example of how Daniel asks
that he and his friends only be given
vegetables and water. And as a result,
it doesn't just say they looked better
and they were healthier. It says in
wisdom and in understanding they were 10
times more which means and I'm just
going to put this plainly. I'm going to
put this plainly. The food you eat
between the table
and the commode
affects your mind.
The idea that it does not, that's the
devil. And so the health message is
getting us back to a level of clarity
particularly in these last days. But it
is not a sin to do what God says we are
allowed to do. We're not earning our way
into the kingdom by eating clean meats,
but we are seeking clear minds by
abstaining from meat.
>> Amen. Amen, Pastor Ryan. Thank you for
that clear explanation. Um, all right,
Pastor James, we're going to come to you
now. Your question comes from uh Rhonda
in Minnesota and she texted this
question and she asks during the
thousand years in heaven before the new
earth is created will we eat from the
tree of life or does that begin only
after we are living on the new earth? I
ask because it seems the Bible may
suggest there is an Eden in heaven not
just on the old and new earth.
>> Thank you Rhonda for that question about
the tree of life in heaven. It's a great
question. And are we going to be
partaking of it in heaven? Yes, I think
you're exactly correct uh in your
biblical understanding of the tree of
life. We can read this in uh Revelation
chapter 22. You know, the Bible says in
Revelation 22 1-5 that John saw um a
pure river of the water of life. It was
clear as crystal. It was uh proceeding
from the throne of God, the lamb. And in
the midst of the street on either side
of this river was the tree of life that
bore this 12 manner of fruit. And then
it talks about how there's not going to
be any more curse and his servants are
going to serve him. They're going to see
his face. So this is talking about the
new Jerusalem. And at this point in
Revelation 22, the new Jerusalem has
already descended down to the earth. But
there are two important things we want
to notice about the new Jerusalem. In
the new Jerusalem, we find God's throne.
And out of God's throne proceeds this
river of life. Now the tree of life is
planted on either side of the river of
life. Now remember the tree of life used
to be in the garden of Eden. But now
it's we find it in Revelation 22 planted
on either side of the of the river of
life which flows from the throne of God.
>> Now let's look at Revelation chap 21 and
we can look there at verses 1-4. John
sees a new heaven and a new earth and
the first heaven and the first earth are
passed away and there's no more sea. And
John sees the holy city, the new
Jerusalem, coming down out of heaven as
a bride adorned for her husband. And
this proclamation is made. Uh the
tabernacle of God is now with men. He's
going to dwell with them. He's going to
be with them. God himself is going to be
with them and be their God. He's going
to wipe away all tears. There's not
going to be any more pain or sorrow. The
former things are all passed away. So
the tree of life is in the New
Jerusalem, which according to the
biblical description is about the size
of the state of Oregon. It's a big city.
Like all the cities of the world could
probably fit inside the New Jerusalem
city. And it's as tall as it is long and
wide. And the river of life flows from
the throne of God which is in the New
Jerusalem. And the tree of life is on
either side of that river. So the tree
of life and the garden of Eden is
presently in heaven. And it will be
transported to this earth in the new
Jerusalem along with God's redeemed
saints. And God himself will be here
with us on planet earth. And in verse 14
of uh Revelation 22, it actually
pronounces a blessing on those who keep
his commandments. They will have right
to the tree of life and enter into the
gates into the city. So when we go to
heaven, that's where the dune Jerusalem
is. That's where the tree of life is. We
have access to the tree of life in
heaven. And then when the new Jerusalem
comes back down to this earth after the
thousand years, the tree of life comes
back down to this earth. It's the in the
same place. It's in the new Jerusalem.
And again, we have access to the tree of
life because the immortality that is
given to us at the resurrection is
promagated. That is it is continued
through our partaking of the tree of
life.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pastor James. You
know, there's we've seen kind of like a
lot of questions here about food and
what we eat. And I just want to, you
know, let us remind ourselves that we
also need to eat from the word of God.
Amen.
>> And with that, uh, you might come
across, you know, some some Bible verses
or maybe a topic or something and you
you have a question about it. Well,
please send in your questions here to
us. There's a couple of ways that you
can do that. You can send it to us by
text through 618-228-3975.
618-228-3975.
You can also email us at bibleqa3abn.tv
or you can send in your question through
Instagram at 3abn_official.
So I want to keep this rolling here.
We're going to jump to you Foutini. And
your next question here was an email
that came from the United Kingdom and
they ask why do we have pictures of
Jesus on book covers or in picture
frames on walls? Wouldn't that be
considered idol worship?
>> It's a good question.
>> Well, let's bring that back to the ten
commandments, which would be the source
of even thinking of what idol worship is
or why it would be bad for us. Let's
look at the second commandment in Exodus
20 uh verse 4 and 5. You shall not make
for yourself a carved image, any
likeness of anything that is in heaven
above, or that is in the earth beneath,
or that is in the water under the sea.
You shall not bow down to them nor serve
them. Now here we have two concepts. We
have first of all likeness like what is
likeness? It's a painting uh art. Then
what about the digital space you have
graphics and all of that but it's
essentially more concerned in the in the
text of a 3D
>> right? So something that was created and
then um the purpose for that was because
Israel had just come out of an Egyptian
out of Egyptian bondage which was
idolatrous and polytheistic at the time
and so it was it was a deliberate point
for them as well and the plagues were
actually strategic in breaking down the
concept of those so but what is idol
worship right so that's actually at the
core of the question what is idol
worship Paul is explicit about what idol
worship is or what idolatry is in
Colossians 3:5. He writes, "Therefore,
put to death your members which are on
the earth, fornication, uncleanness,
passion, evil desire, and covetousness,
which is idolatry." So now we have in
addition to the 3D imagery, we also have
concepts that that consist of uh
different things. And in the Greek the
word for that is eidol latria which
literally means to worship an image
something that is a replica of
something. And in this particular verse
we see umbrella concepts that could
include a lot of things. So but what
does image worship actually look like?
We have bow down right which is to
prostrate oneself in worship. We have to
serve which is essentially kind of to
enslave yourself to something. And we
read that in Isaiah 48:5 what that could
look like.
Isaiah writes, "Even from the beginning,
I have declared it to you. Before it
came to pass, I proclaimed it to you,
lest you should say, my idol done has
done them, and my carved image and my
molded image have commanded them." Which
means that Israel actually had a
relationship or could have had a
relationship with these images. And
that's what idolatry looks like. And I
can speak from personal experience from
that growing up in the Greek Orthodox
church. There is a difference between
having an image that you look at that
reminds you of Jesus versus an image
that you have to bow down to and kiss
and put flowers on and adorn before you
can even go into the church.
>> That is the difference that I see
between idolatry in concerning um the
image of Jesus. Now the danger does
become real when we start to worship the
material aspect of that image. I brought
a very brief example of the Sabbath
school quarterly that indeed has a
picture of Jesus on it. Now, I don't
believe that the book can curse me if I
accidentally drop it. I don't believe
that my household will be cursed if I
don't have one.
>> I don't believe that uh this will save
me if I, you know, take it to bed with
me, put it under my pillow or what have
you. But, however, the Bible does say
that there is one image that we are to
look to and worship. And we read that in
Colossians 1:15-17.
He, speaking of Jesus, our Lord and
Savior, is the image of the invisible
God, the firstborn over all creation.
For by him all things were created that
are in heaven and that are on earth,
visible and invisible, whether thrones
or dominions or principalities or
powers. All things were created through
him and for him. And he is before all
things, and in him all things consist.
This is the image that we are to look
to, and it is the only image that saves.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen, sister. Thank you for that.
>> That's great,
>> Pastor Ryan.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Uh we have a text from Brenda in
Illinois, and she asks, "Is it wrong to
live with someone with whom you are not
intimate?"
>> First of all, that was great, Sister
Fina.
>> Um, is it wrong to live with someone
with whom you're not intimate? You know,
I hear I think I hear two questions in
here. So, let's let's see if we can get
to both of them. Um, she may be asking,
you may be asking, Sister Brenda, is it
wrong to be married to someone, living
with them, and not be intimate, you
know. Um, and in my pastoral experience,
I've seen a spectrum of relationships
and there are some marriages and they
are faithful to one another. They don't
step outside. They just don't have
intimacy. There is no sin in that and
they cohabit. Um, so, you know, if that
is what works, by God's grace, that is
what works. But at the same time, you
could be asking, is it wrong to live
with someone I'm going to assume of the
opposite gender and stay out of all of
that there to whom one is not married?
And is that a sin? So, let's go ahead
and have a look at it. I'm going to use
Sister Fotini's method of using the the
actual law and the word to define sin.
The Bible says in 1 John 3:4 that sin is
the transgression of God's law. That's
what it is. The law helps us see what
sin is. Paul says that and there is no
commandment that explicitly forbids
cohabitation with someone with whom you
are not married. But I'd like to ask a
question. Is it wise?
Not just is it wrong, but is it wise?
You know, there are commandments that
tell us how to guard our minds and
hearts. I'm talking about the 10th
commandment there. Lest we sin, coveting
and stuff. Well, there are some
exceptions to cohabiting. If there's a
big big age difference, you're renting
family arrangements, if there's an
emergency, you know, don't be on the
street if the Lord has made provision.
But remember this biblical principle.
This is in Romans chapter 14 and verse
16. I love this. I remember the first
time I heard this. It says, "Let not
then your good be evil spoken of." Your
life is a witness. You want to avoid
misunderstanding. You want to avoid
temptation within reason because the
devil is crafty. And so we want to avoid
situations where temptation and falling
may arise. So many times, brother Ian,
we see things that went down that should
not have gone down, but it's because we
put ourselves in a bad position. So we
want to avoid that. I like the story of
Elijah the prophet who was staying with
the widow at Zerapath but he was in his
own place. He made sure that even the
appearance of unrighteousness did not
take place. We are called upon to do
this because whether or not you consider
yourself a preacher, you are preaching
by the way you live your life. And we
want to make sure we do not lead others
astray by how we do our good as it were.
So it is not explicitly a sin. There are
always special circumstances. But we
should ask what honors God? What
protects my integrity? And we should
conduct ourselves accordingly.
>> Amen. Thank you, Pastor Ryan. Like how
you said, we don't just preach with our
words, but we're preaching in our
actions as well. Amen. All right, Pastor
James, we have a text here that came in
from Delaware. And this the viewer asks,
"Can you please explain Revelation 19
17-9? Is it literal or symbolic?"
>> Oh, thank you for your question from
Delaware. This is definitely a symbolic
representation of a literal event. uh
symbols are used to help us to
understand events that end up being
literal, but the symbols aren't
necessarily going to be taken literally,
but they're going to represent
something. This is going to happen at
the second return or the second coming
of Jesus Christ. Now, if we take a
closer look at the context of these
verses, we can see what the Bible is
telling us and we'll get a clearer
answer to the question. And I saw an
angel, it says, standing in the sun. He
cries with a loud voice, saying to all
the fowls that are in the midst of
heaven, come and gather yourselves
together unto the supper of the great
God, that you may eat the flesh of kings
and the flesh of captains and the flesh
of mighty men, the flesh of horses, and
the flesh of them that sit on them, the
flesh of all men, free bond, small,
great. And I saw the beast, that's
symbolic, and the kings of the earth and
their armies gathered together to make
war against him that sat on the horse.
Again, I think this is symbolic language
and against his army. And the beast was
taken with him, the false prophet,
symbols of certain entities that are
fighting against Christ as he returns on
a horse symbol symbolic of power and
authority. Uh that work miracles before
him that deceived them that had received
the mark of the beast, again symbolic.
And them that had worshiped his image,
again symbolic. Both of these were cast
alive into the lake of fire, symbolic,
burning with fire and brimstone. and the
remnant were slain with the sword of him
that sat on the horse again symbolic of
the word of God. By the way, the sword
that proceeded out of his mouth, and all
the fowls were filled with their flesh.
There's some literalness there because
you've got uh bodies, dead bodies
perhaps being eaten by the fowls of
heaven. And I saw an angel come down
from heaven having a in his hand a key
of the bottomless pit. As we go into the
next chapter, chapter 20, we see again
the symbolism is continued. This is all
talking about what's going to happen at
the very end of time. When we compare
these verses with Revelation 15, uh,
12-6, the battle of Armageddon,
Revelation 17, Revelation 18, we find
that Revelation 19 is a continuation of
the same picture from a different
prophetic angle. And we see the beast
and the false prophet thrown into the
lake of fire. That's not talking about
an individual. was talking about a
system, the system of Babylon that has
been imaged or reflected in another
system that was a lamb beast with
lamblike horns. When it says they're
thrown into the lake of fire, it means
that they're destroyed. Doesn't mean
they're sitting in a place, some person
is sitting in a place burning. It's
talking about they're coming to a
complete end. They're being destroyed.
Later after the thousand years, Satan
himself, it joins these two systems in
the lake of fire, which means he also is
destroyed. These two systems are
destroyed at the coming of Christ and
then Satan joins them after the thousand
years. So there's a lot of symbolism
here, but basically what you're looking
at is the symbolic language is picturing
the second coming of Christ when all who
receive the mark of the beast are
destroyed, taken out. The fowls of the
air, feed on them as their bodies lie
decay, and the devil himself is sealed
up in this prison house of circumstances
until after the thousand years when he
himself is judged along with the rest of
the wicked.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pastor James. We
only got a few short moments here. So, I
want to make sure that we get all the
questions in. So, I'm going to come
quickly to you, Foutini. All right. Your
question comes from Ben, who sent an
email, and he asks, "I went to a store a
couple of times, and both times the
clerk gave me less change than he should
have. I'm probably not the only one
affected. How should a child of God
respond in this situation?"
>> Absolutely. Let's jump right into the
word of God. Let's read in Matthew 5:44.
We read, "But I say to you, love your
enemies, bless those who curse you, do
good to those who hate you, and pray for
those who spitefully use you and
persecute you." And now in the book of
Luke, we read concerning that a little
bit more. It reads, "To him who strikes
you on the one cheek, offer the other
also. And from him who takes away your
cloak or who steals from you,
essentially do not withhold your tunic
either. Give to everyone who asks of
you. and from him who takes away your
goods, do not ask them back. Just as a
disclaimer, I'd like to add that I am
not speaking about situations where you
are abused or you are being harmed in
this situation or you do not feel
comfortable bringing something to
somebody's attention. I am using these
verses in the context of a small dispute
that could be resolved with a couple of
conversations or a couple of acts of
kindness.
Because in 1 Thessalonians we read 5:15,
"See that no one renders evil for evil
to anyone,
but always pursue what is good, both for
yourselves and for all." So essentially,
what this means is that we're not called
to passively just accept people doing
wrong to us. Rather, we're called to
have an active response of rendering
good for evil. Now, what does that look
like particularly?
Well,
in this situation, we don't really know
why this is happening. There's a lot of
things that need to come into
consideration. Is this somebody who's
differently aabled, who has a hard time
in that situation. Is this someone who
was absent-minded and didn't pay
attention? Is he possibly doing it
deliberately, but needing money to pay
for a bill or buy diapers? I don't know.
There's a lot of situations that come
from that and ultimately God is the only
true judge of those things which is why
we are called to play our role in
deliberately doing good for evil.
But why though? Well, because we have
the sacred possibility of preserving
someone from error. We want to bring
people closer to God. As Pastor Ryan
Johnson mentioned, our lives and the way
we conduct ourselves or what
particularly in times where we've been
wronged really brings to the forefront
who we serve and it also showcases that
our actions are not determined by how we
are treated but rather whom we have
chosen by whom we've chosen to follow.
And in that context,
you really need to be prayerful first
and foremost. John 16:8 tells us that
the Holy Spirit will bring discernment,
convict the world of sin. But then we
also read to let our light so shine
before men again for the purpose that
they may see our good works and glorify
God in heaven. Now I know it's hard to
take those deliberate steps of providing
good in the face of evil, especially
when you already perceive that you've
been wronged and especially in a world
that is more accustomed to taking rather
than giving. However, through God's
infinite grace and his mercy and his
provisions that he's given to us, we are
called to share that with others as well
that we might bring others to the way,
the truth, and the life.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you so much, Fini.
>> Pastor Ryan, real quickly.
>> Yeah.
>> Why do drums carry a stigma in the
church?
>> No, no, that's Yeah, it's a powerful
question. Um, I hear two in here. First,
is it wrong to uh use drums in church?
And then why the stigma? Well, let's use
the same process that we've been using.
Is there a commandment against drums and
church? There is not. But there are
commandments about how to reverence God.
Don't take his name in vain. Have him
first. So, I think the question as far
as drums is concerned is, are we
reverencing God? And I'm just going to
leave that to the person there. I tend
to be more conservative, but we have to
be careful not to let our preference be
confused for that which is right. So,
I'll just leave us to consider that. To
me, the bigger issue right now is why
there's a stigma. The devil likes to
take our good intentions and use it to
split us up. Politics and drums and this
and that and the other as we march
toward the kingdom doing our best. Let's
determine, let's make a pact that by
God's grace, we not allow these issues
to divide us. You worship where you're
comfortable and you worship in the
reverent way by God's grace that he
leads you to. But remember, we are one
church and let's not allow these issues
to split us up.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you for that quick
answer. I know you didn't have a whole
lot of time. We are unfortunately
running out of time here, but we just
want to go to a quick break and we'll be
right back.
>> If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
>> Well, welcome back. Thank you for
sticking with us. We just have a few
moments here for closing comments. So,
Pastor James, I'll just start with you.
I noticed that the questions that I got
were all from the book of Revelation.
And the one that wasn't from the book of
Revelation was an end time prophecy. 1
Timothy chapter 4. I just think it's
interesting that people are the Holy
Spirit is moving people to really study
some of these end time prophecies and
especially uh the book of Revelation.
It's present truth for God's people
today.
>> Amen.
>> All right, Fini. I really urge everyone
to go back to Exodus 16 and read about
the parameters that God established when
he provided the mana for the children of
Israel because in that you also find the
gem of the Sabbath where he instructed
them to not go out on the Sabbath and
collect it. And when they did, he was
actually mad about it because he's like,
"This is when we're supposed to be
together." And so the Lord wants to
tabernacle with us. And we see that in
his covenant represented also in the
golden pot of mana.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Yeah.
>> Amen. Pastor Ryan,
>> you know, um, a lot of the questions
that I had were what I call like
pastoral questions. You'll encounter
those people asking, "What do you think
about this or how I should eat or where
you should worship and stuff?" And we do
have different opinions. We're all doing
our best by God's grace. I do want to
reiterate the importance of us sticking
together as God's people. Let us not
allow the minutia of how we feel to
split us up. We serve one God into one
kingdom.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, thank you, Pastor
Ryan. Thank you, Foutini. Thank you,
Pastor James, for being with us. And we
want to thank you for sticking around,
for sending in your questions and
studying with us. And I want to leave
you with this. This comes from Numbers
chapter 6. And it says, "Speak to Aaron
and his son, saying this way, you shall
bless the children of Israel and say to
them,
>> yes,
>> the Lord bless you and keep you. The
Lord make his face shine upon you and be
gracious to you. The Lord lift up his
countenance upon you and give you
peace." Amen.
>> Until next time, God bless you. God
bless. Heat. Heat.
Heat.